[Music]
so it turns out
and i think jk news has a little bit of
egg on our faces no way
for once
it turns out that the scientists
at the at the cern hadron collider
are in fact
not
communicating with demonic entities and
opening a portal to hell
you don't say who are they talking to
them i don't know but it's apparently
not that so who yeah who was it
so
in april scientists at the european
organization for nuclear research or
cern
uh restarted their particle accelerator
the world's largest and most powerful
accelerator after after a three year
hiatus
the accelerator the large hadron
collider has undergone repairs and
upgrades you know you guys know it's
like a it's like [ __ ] gigantic
[ __ ] huge built underneath all this
sub terrain the particle
accelerator yes thank you nice that was
really good um
the they plan to use it to crash protons
together
sort of like what what the dancer's
doing here geek [ __ ] and learn more
about the origins of the universe like
through studying what's happening try to
do minion big bangs right yeah study the
reaction
um however
that's sort of irrelevant because social
media users are suggesting that the
machine has a different purpose
um to talk to the devil like [ __ ]
mass destruction
the commenters have have some theories
there was a facebook post shared july
5th these scientists are beefing with
everybody which is a facebook post
sharing a tick tock video
of a woman who claims that certain
scientists are using the machine to open
a doorway for demons we need to
interview her she sounds more credible
no are you guys laughing she should be a
guest on the show we need someone that's
going to tell us the truth because we're
truth seekers here yeah we're trying to
we have metal detectors on the beach of
the truth and we're just looking for
beats
and when she posted a video that [ __ ]
went
big time you know big time for us
she says if you all don't know about
cern it's a demonic evil machine that
opens up portals to other dimensions
y'all hell that's not even an acronym
other spiritual worlds
it brings demons wicked spirits high
evil
that's what it says in the post so what
what's the acronym is it s-e-r-n c-e-r-t
c-e-r-n anything that's legit as an
acronym okay so in her head what does it
stand for like like like c is for
christian oh well she said demon
she said her own but she didn't even
make an acting amount of those words
she's like cosmic endoplasmic [ __ ]
radioactive [ __ ]
neurological
or whatever but it's all sounds like
science evil to her oh evil science yeah
yeah yeah so but there's a lot of posts
about this like there's a lot of
speculation about this there's a lot of
talk about how the cern collider is
going to end the universe as we know it
but they're like this is how they're
going to [ __ ] blow it up
right by experimenting with stuff they
probably like read like uh angels and
demons
anybody read that i didn't read it i uh
read the movie
i didn't even know how they
matter of particles and stuff like that
anti-mata anti-matter that have like the
ability to like [ __ ] pretty much like
bombs right it's like you put that in
somewhere you can [ __ ] blow [ __ ] up
or like re like if it goes into the
earth's core
like eat the [ __ ] earth inside out
into like a black hole and [ __ ] like
that is that pretty much what she's
saying in terms of this gateway to hell
not to speak for her but yes i like how
she's like smoking a cigarette in her
[ __ ] car in the walmart parking lot
and scrolling through and then she sees
this cern [ __ ] and she's like holy [ __ ]
do they know what they're doing and
they're just taking her files out of her
like peach folder and stuff from like
elementary school yeah she checks her
cigarette lighter and then she looks and
she opens her little mini fridge in the
car and she sees that her jello shots
aren't ready yet and she closes it
and then
she's back to the post back to the post
i like that she knows more than these
[ __ ] scientists you know she doesn't
know we don't know her credibility i
like that she only knows about it after
the thing's been built not the [ __ ]
decades it was being planned yeah i just
can't believe how sick this machine is
the fact that we can do this and the
fact that it
it uses a strong magnetic field to
accelerate charged particles or proton
at very high energies in a circular
circular tunnel and when two beams of
these particles collide detectors which
are located around the beams record the
outcome of those collisions and that's
what they're studying right it's the
nascar of science it is indeed but the
but the accidents are even more
important the craziest part about
science to me
is that us as a species we've been able
to
like find the laws that determine this
world yeah and then we use those laws to
our benefit like porn yeah it's crazy
how exactly is it like we use the
internet to have unlimited free supply
of porn just to like maybe go off what
he's talking about can you give us an
example
so one of them like even in a form of
just art like music right like we've
determined like from like like del rey
mifas or whatever we know each frequency
is however many thousands of the other
one so we can predict the next note the
next note the next note we know
these two notes with these other two
notes are gonna be in harmony this one
will be like off key and so like we can
use that to predict things or we could
even use like okay this is the buoyancy
of water we put this thing this thing
floats we can take something that weighs
tons but if we fold it a certain way
this can become a ship so we've taken
like the laws of this world and we've
been able to like
[ __ ] have jello shot mini fridges in
our [ __ ] rooms way to incorporate put
a [ __ ] thing in the wall unit and
it's like a hundred degrees not anymore
[ __ ] [ __ ] 69 or whatever you
can like
69.
cold air it's just crazy as a human
species but you know where scientists
still fail
they still can't figure out what women
want to eat that's true they don't know
they don't know no matter what man they
don't they'll say
anything
and then
is it really anything ever
answer that scientist
[Laughter]
that's what i think is so funny about
people who
contribute nothing to the invention of
anything and they just go go ahead world
invent whatever you want i'll sit back
and tell you if it's evil or not yeah
yeah yeah yeah
why i won't make anything do you think
osama bin laden's wife knew what she
wants to eat or even her
tell me what do you want to eat for
lunch i really don't know
the pressure is hard for me to make it
he goes okay we'll get kebabs she goes
can we get something else
i'm okay with anything
hello
he's like okay we get kebabs you order
whatever you want from that and then
she's like looking through the phone
she's like
[Laughter]
okay so you don't want to order kebabs
okay what do you want you know [ __ ]
the best you're killing me
we have kebabs last two steps
you're terrorizing me
[Laughter]
again
the best part about this is that
pre-nikki i i'm so glad i had pre-nikki
to know all this because nikki's just
like i don't know whatever i just want
to talk about so it's like it's always
taco bell that's always talk about it
that's helpful though when someone knows
what they want yeah even if it's every
day it's like okay i know what they want
yeah she knows exactly what she wants
yeah last night she's like she's like
give me [ __ ] shrimp scampi she's like
give me [ __ ] i want chocolate shrimp
scampi you know chocolate shrimp
scallions chocolate and chopsticks
i was like that's next level
oh so i just go down there i'm like yo
give me give me a job give me some
chocolate
chip
i was like what store is this it's crazy
but because i'm just so glad i have
other frames of references because i
remember all those you laugh about it
yeah [ __ ] yeah it's not a nightmare
because it doesn't happen not anymore
that's why i can't wait till after geo
because she's still in this face
[Laughter]
your post geo renaissance is gonna be
crazy crazy
20 23ag you get to eat whatever you want
yeah because she's still a g is very
good what's what happens first after geo
or jk news is dead
what's the over under here maybe both
probably both it's around the same year
i think geogra last longer yeah i just
like that we went from like large hadron
collider all the way to osama bin
laden's why did you think about it
so [ __ ] good
i get it
can we get like tacos or something we
are in a cave in the middle of pakistan
well he was actually at a very nice
facility later oh that's true the the
two-story house
yeah you probably he went into the cave
because tired of her ass complaining all
day sure i will go into man cave with
friends he went to a real man cave
that's the only reason he did any of
that is just to get away from her
finally i can eat the kebabs in peace
i know a way we can be in the cave no
robot
the plan sounds a little complex
i know how to get away from my wife if i
only beheld people she doesn't like
blood so i'm going to be happy you want
to be here
he sounds like noho
never really did any of that can i just
say too better uh acting than history
channel reenactment
there's no question we should actually
[Laughter]
30 for 30. 30 for 30.
osama bin laden but we re-enact it and
we ride it hey that's not bad i don't
know why it's a sport
we got to make it a sports starter
that just shows how much he loves sports
he doesn't even know what 3430 is no
it's it's for osama bin laden though
because he's an accomplishment we'll
make it like a sports story like the
last day yeah
dude osama's last dance
that's fire bro
dude i'm i'm in alzheimer here he's like
he's like he's scottie biffen's like i
knew he's like we all knew he's like
he's like so they so we get a call he's
like and then they say yeah you're out
after this and i was like and that's
when we all looked at each other and we
knew
this was the last day
the guy who produces 30 30 he's my
neighbor and he said he never turns down
a pitch really yeah so if you want osama
bin laden
i think we're going to be his first
i don't know if i want to hear that
that'd be amazing real talk though
imagine getting george bush junior yeah
w you lost me already because they're
friends
the bin laden family and the bush family
they go way [ __ ] back so i'll like i
want the bush to talk about his old
buddy you're scaring the normans they
haven't read house of bush houses sod
okay never mind maybe we'll just stick
to the 30-day beyonce version i like
that
that was kind of fun
you